I'm in Jackson, Mississippi.
With some amazing talent.
I got Marvin Hunter,
Merc William,
Rita Brent, and Ben Compton.
If you guys could
describe comedy
in Jackson, Mississippi
in one word,
what would you describe it as?
- I would say growing.
- Growing.
Because typically, you
think about Mississippi,
you think about fried
chicken and Morgan Freeman.
You don't think about comedy.
But now-- now, you can
think about comedy.
I love the
intimate comedy room.
I don't think there's a better
setting that's so close knit,
you feel like you know them.
How long have you
been doing comedy?
About three years now.
Three years.
Rita actually brought
me to Jackson originally.
She seen me on YouTube,
brought me to a show
she was putting on.
Why did you grab him?
What happened?
To be honest, I needed
some diversity on the show.
And he's white.
So that's why I had
to get him for that.
I love that.
Flat out honesty.
To be honest, I
needed a white boy.
- And he's funny.
- What about you?
How long you been doing comedy?
Two years now.
It all happened by mistake.
What?
I have an identical
twin brother.
OK.
He moved to Memphis,
but he still had gigs.
And so I was like, hey, let
me host your gigs for you.
Y'all did a twin switch.
Literally.
This happened like that.
They thought I was him.
And he lives in Atlanta now.
So I'm pretty sure he's
on the streets right now,
saying y'all gonna see
me on "Hart of the City."
I'm pretty sure
he gonna say that.
What's your style
of comedy, Marvin?
Grumpy uncle.
KEVIN HART: The grumpy uncle?
Yeah, grumpy uncle.
Is that what you
are in real life?
Yeah.
I got divorced.
Heifer took everything, so--
oh, yeah.
KEVIN HART: That's
what pissed you off?
Oh, yeah.
KEVIN HART: Angry
about everything.
MARVIN HUNTER: About everything.
About everything.
We are performing at the
Next Level Experience.
Is there a little bit of fear
for your performance tonight?
BEN COMPTON: Hell yeah.
I feel like in doing comedy,
you always have-- you always
have a fear at each show.
Just like being
in the military.
I've been to war zone.
You step on the stage, man, in
front of people, same feeling.
Your skin crawls.
But you got to do
what you got to do.
I don't know if
I can compare--
a war to the stage.
It's the same feeling.
It's the same anxiety.
You gonna see a different
level of Kevin Hart
if a bullet flies past my
head, but I don't if you--
if I'm gonna get
to the punch line.
[inaudible]